[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants pas trop d'accord
mon gros nounours montre dans le livre
et je vais le raconter d'histoires et
hop
mon dieu potron joue plus ou moins de
cheveux tu es trop pressé nounours deux
cols là on le shale sommes au point où
se forment les au fond de moi nounours
nous qu'est ce que tu nous as apporté
tu vois bien que c'est un livre d'image
comme les enfants mittal là je vois là
comme vous avez été très sage je vais
vous montrer un bon livre d'image et
notre ami le marchand de sable va vous
en raconter une histoire ce cas là c'est
qu'ils eastman l'histoire de notre ami
blanchi et des saunas gros vous autres
ont fait le printemps le jardin de yang
chut chut le petit chinois est
maintenant très beau il est plein de
fleurs
il y a des boutons de roses des fleurs
d'orangers et de pommiers des fleurs sur
les cerisiers qui ont bien pousser des
fleurs partout
oui est-ce qu'elles sont dell ayant reçu
fait le tour de son jardin avec dix ans
et il admire le fruit de leur travail
il y a des fleurs bien sûr mais
mais il manque quelque chose des
feuilles fond il n'y a pas d'oiseau pas
un seul oiseau et le jardin de yang chut
chut est bien triste sans oiseaux à
longnan viens avec moi
nous allons au marché acheter des
oiseaux dix ans que je suis au d'accord
répond il en est
ils partent tous deux sur la grande
route tout à coup qu'est ce qu'ils
entendent dit oiseaux mais oui un petit
oiseau qui pleure et il pleure parce que
gros vilain l'a enfermé à clef dans une
horrible cage avec de gros barreaux sans
même lui donner à manger aux idiots ils
exagèrent celui là donc si tu prend son
bâton et eau sur le poteau croûte
non il lui dit d'abord aux vilains il ne
faut pas enfermer ce petit oiseau dans
une cage et le laisser sans nourriture
et par rapport à sa tête un gros vilain
qui part se cacher tout honteux derrière
un arbre dans la forêt pardon et yang
chut je te promets que je ne le ferai
plus violent que juju ouvre la cage
et le petit oiseau s'envole jusqu'au
jardin du petit chinois et nos amis yang
chu pays en sont très contents car leur
nouvel ami a fait venir tous les petits
oiseaux du pays dans le jardin qui est
maintenant habité et qui résonne 2000
champ dit comment il s'appelle le petit
oiseau nonos nous voient pas l'histoire
et fait qu'elle était jolie c'est
histoire
merci petit marchand de sable
allons plus petit odudu
[Musique]
boni mais peut-on la jute à la hâte au
bond
venu une hausse à demain tenus nicolas
produit par prenait
[Musique]
alors les enfants l'histoire vous a plu
oui tant mieux si vous êtes bien sage
on vous en racontera d'autres
et maintenant allez vite vous coucher
allons en route mon chien nounours
bonne nuit les enfants fais de beaux
rêves
à demain fêtes de bourg est atteint
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]